[Music]
as we mentioned breaking tonight
at the top we're giving you the first
look tonight at new fox polls for
several
battleground states not good news for
the president in these polls joe biden
leads in pennsylvania
50-39 president has lost three points
since april in 2016
candidate trump won that state by less
than one percentage point
in michigan the margin is nine 49 to 40.
that's a one-point gain again for biden
president trump won that state four
years ago
by three tenths of a percent and in
minnesota biden is up 13 points 51-38
donald trump lost that state in 2016
by one and a half percent to hillary
clinton the two men who will be at the
top of the ticket in november are
spending this week arguing
over racism joe biden says president
trump is the first racist elected to the
top job
the president says that's an affront to
african americans
and the trump campaign is pointing back
to joe biden's past comments
correspondent peter ducey has the latest
tonight
joe biden believes 45 is a first
we have racist and they've existed
they've tried to get elected president
he's the first one that has
president trump's campaign says this is
an insult to the intelligence of black
voters
and trump himself is trying to add
historical context
i've done more for black americans than
anybody
with the possible exception of abraham
lincoln
12 u.s presidents at some point in their
lives owned
slaves woodrow wilson's name was just
stripped from a school at princeton
because of his past
segregationist policies and andrew
jackson is set to be replaced within a
decade on the 20
bill design by harriet tubman after
review of
his record of mistreating slaves and
native americans
but biden insists trump is the first
racist the way he pits people against
one another
is all designed to divide the country
divide people if there's one biden
attack on trump that's been consistent
since day one
it's this the central theme of his
announcement video was
president trump's response to deadly
race riots in charlottesville
he said there were quote some very
fine people on both sides very fine
people on both sides
registered voters in a new fox news poll
trust biden over trump on every leading
issue in battleground minnesota
but trump has more trust on the economy
in battlegrounds michigan and
pennsylvania
now biden is hoping to hold his overall
lead with help
from his old boss what kind of values
are you communicating
bingo that's part of a 15-minute long
streaming campaign video with
biden and obama who reportedly got paid
50 million dollars to develop
streaming content for netflix but it
appears he did this one
for his former vp for free right
all right peter thank you